vi racconto come ho deciso di occuparmi
40 anni fa della lotta contro i tumori
occupandomi delle persone che hanno
questa malattia ricordo perfettamente la
storia era uno studente di medicina del
quarto anno di medicina
frequentava un'istituzione importante il
policlinico di milano una clinica medica
e come ben immaginate gli studenti fanno
il giro con il professore con i vari
assistenti e in questo giro vengono
fuori tutte delle cose molto così molto
sagge molto dotte e noi facevamo questo
giro però girando tre pazienti c'era una
paziente che aveva un tumore del polmone
con metastasi alla pleura quindi con del
liquido nella pleura di fronte alla
quale ci fermavamo praticamente pochi
secondi il tempo di dire a questa
paziente qualche pietosa bugia e poi di
andare avanti perché tanto questa
signora aveva un cancro e quindi non
c'era niente da fare secondo quelli che
erano i paradigmi di allora io ho deciso
che mi sarei occupato di lei e di tutti
i pazienti come lei ma soprattutto delle
persone come legge delle persone che non
erano
considerate allora uguali agli altri
ammalati perché non c'era niente da fare
perché era una brutta malattia il male
incurabile
innominabile come ancora oggi purtroppo
molte volte si vede sui giornali e sulla
stampa è cominciato quindi un percorso e
vi voglio raccontare come è stato questo
percorso negli anni perché le cose sono
cambiate
sono cambiate perché sono cambiate
queste malattie
oggi non abbiamo esattamente lo stesso
tipo di incidenza cioè di nuovi casi di
tumore come avevamo 40 anni fa il faccio
alcuni esempi pensiamo al tumore dello
stomaco che una volta era uno dei tumori
più frequenti
adesso è diminuito come incidenza come
nuovi casi
perché sono cambiate le abitudini
alimentari perché si usano meno alimenti
affumicati mal conservati e diminuito il
tumore dell'utero perché tutti sanno che
grazie al pap test è più facile fare una
diagnosi di forme pre tumorali quindi di
evitare che il tumore insorga e poi c'è
la vaccinazione contro il papilloma
virus che si fa in età molto precoce e
quindi questi tumori sono ridotti però
purtroppo altri sono aumentati per
esempio aumentato il tumore del colon
anche questo legato all'alimentazione
un'alimentazione troppo ricca di grassi
troppo povera di fibre vegetali una vita
troppo sedentaria fanno aumentare questo
tumore il tumore della mammella che
colpisce molto perché molte donne sono
colpite da questa malattia è in una
diciamo leggera salita e questa salita è
legata al cambiamento della vita
riproduttiva si fanno meno figli di
serrata di meno si fa una vita diversa
anche rispetto a una volta
oppure ci sono dei tumori come il tumore
della prostata che un po l'equivalente
del tumore della mammella nelle donne
come la prostata colpisce gli uomini
ovviamente ed è un tumore che spesso è
quasi sovra diagnosticato perché c'è un
utilizzo a volte financo eccessivo del
psa quindi di un test nel sangue che
serve a creare il sospetto che ci sia la
malattia e poi ci sono altri tumori un
paradigma può essere quello del melanoma
che sono legati anche questi a un
abitudine di vita diversa in questo caso
ha un'esposizione eccessiva e
irrazionale al sole
queste cose sono cambiate e quindi noi
oggi abbiamo delle malattie diverse da
quelle che avevamo 40 anni fa e
soprattutto possiamo dire questa è una
nota positiva quando si parla di un
argomento così pesante che globalmente
la mortalità dei tumori è diminuita
quindi ci sono alcuni tumori aumentati
come numero altri diminuiti ma
globalmente le persone che guariscono
sono di più tanto che oggi nel nostro
paese si calcola che ci siano circa due
milioni e mezzo di cosiddetti
sopravviventi al tumore persone che sono
guarite o che hanno un'elevata
possibilità di essere guariti
questo grazie alla prevenzione e quindi
non ci stancheremo mai di dire quanto è
importante la prevenzione prevenzione
primaria
quindi ridurre gli stili di vita
cambiare gli stili di vita pericolosi ma
anche prevenzione secondaria quindi
partecipare agli screening ma anche
grazie alle terapie le terapie oggi sono
terapie
sempre più mirate cioè terapie che danno
dei risultati positivi ma che mantengono
anche una ottimale qualità di vita
quindi la chirurgia è meno aggressiva
meno demolitiva la radioterapia è più
precisa la terapia con i farmaci e oggi
una terapia più diretta contro il
bersaglio
quindi credo che possiamo dare un'idea
da una terapia pesante che attaccava
tutto l'organismo a una terapia mirata
che va contro il tumore salvando quella
che è la vita normale della persona ma
non è solo questo non è solo avere meno
casi a seconda dei tipi di tumore
guarire di più
curare di meglio la qualità di vita del
paziente e anche prendersi carico
globalmente dell'individuo ammalato c'è
oggi un progetto importante che è quello
delle cure palliative
parola che in italiano non suona tanto
bene per quando diciamo pagliativo
pensiamo a qualcosa che non funziona poi
tanto si fa tanto per fare invece non è
assolutamente vero quando parliamo di
cure palliative
noi ci riferiamo a questo mito che poi
in realtà un fatto storico
questo e san martino di tours un santo
che diede metà del suo mantello a un
individuo povero probabilmente ammalato
e questo mantello questo pallium come si
dice il latino avvolgeva l'ammalato
svolgeva la persona sofferente
aiutandola a soffrire di meno quindi mi
sembra un concetto molto bello qui si
parla molto oggi di bellezza
io penso che non sia niente di più bello
che aiutare una persona sofferente anche
una cosa non solo giusta ma ripeto anche
bella da una soddisfazione veramente a
chi la fa e quindi globalmente se
possiamo usare un termine inglese sapete
che medicina non solo in medicina ma si
usano molti termini inglesi noi passiamo
da un concetto di cure cioè di cura con
l'obiettivo di guarigione perché in
realtà in inglese che vorrebbe dire
guarigione che nei tumori e possibile
inoltre metà dei casi ma chiaramente non
in tutti a un concetto di che io cioè
prendersi cura prendersi carico della
individuo malato e anche di chi gli sta
intorno della sua famiglia
queste sono cose importanti sono cose
che sono molto cambiate negli anni e che
hanno portato veramente a un cambiamento
di prospettiva nell'assistenza ai malati
di tumore
credo che sia molto importante e siamo a
bergamo cercare di capire che cosa
stiamo facendo nella nostra città
rispetto a questi ammalati e quindi vi
pongo alcune immagini che danno l'idea
di quello che stiamo facendo
questo è il nostro ospedale papa
giovanni xxiii nel quale esistono delle
aree di eccellenza non sono pochissime
non sono poco rilevanti ce ne sono
alcune molto storiche ma anche molto
attuali come trapianti prima si è
parlato di trapianti bisogna sapere che
a bergamo le cose vanno bene per quanto
riguarda i trapianti
altre sono nel cuore di tutti come
prendersi carico dei bambini e prendersi
carico di chi ha dei problemi acuti di
qualunque tipo però un area molto
importante non superiore alle altre ma
di grande rilevanza e quella dei tumori
quindi abbiamo fondato il cancer center
l'ospedale con una volta un termine
inglese per dire ci mettiamo tutti
insieme ad affrontare questo problema
ancora una volta il concetto di bellezza
perché è bello lavorare in un call
center che ne cancers center i problemi
scientifici sono
centrati sulla persona hanno il volto di
una persona
l'abbiamo detto fin dall'inizio e a
queste persone noi vogliamo dare una
speranza per dare questo non bastano
però le buone intenzioni non basta
essere di spirito caritatevole questa è
un po la base che ci deve essere ma
assolutamente non è sufficiente bisogna
essere un gruppo una squadra lavorare
insieme lavorare vicino
discutere anche a volte litigare bisogna
sapere che i medici sono spesso delle
figure competitive ma questo è
importante perché bisogna lavorare in un
gruppo per ottenere i migliori risultati
non ci sono solo i medici ci sono gli
infermieri che sono importantissimi ci
sono i ricercatori che stanno in
laboratorio ci sono gli psicologi ci
sono i volontari in ospedali ci sono le
figure di assistenza sociale tutte
insieme lavorano a favore del paziente
quindi questi sono i pilastri della
realizzazione di un cancers ente
professionisti che comunque lavorano tra
loro in un modo organizzato al servizio
del paziente e della sua famiglia con
una tecnologia adeguata altrimenti non
otteniamo i risultati e facendo ricerca
si cura meglio dove si fa ricerca
queste immagini del semaforo quindi noi
abbiamo diversi tipi di punti su cui
lavoriamo ci sono dei punti su cui siamo
ancora fermi quindi semaforo rosso quali
sono ad esempio beh vi ho detto che
vogliamo fare questa cura simultanea ma
abbiamo appena cominciato a farla in
modo organizzato
vogliamo seguire quelli che sono i di ex
malati quindi lungo sopravviventi che
possono avere dei problemi anche dopo
anni
magari legati anche alle terapie e
questi meritano di avere un'accoglienza
specifica e poi ho fatto l'esempio della
cardioncologia perché bisogna sapere che
malati di tumore possono avere anche
delle complicanze a livello cardiaco
collegate alla malattia e alle terapie e
quindi capite bene che cardiologi
oncologi devono lavorare insieme poi ci
sono delle aree dove abbiamo già da un
po cominciato a lavorare ma ancora
dobbiamo migliorare pensate agli anziani
gli anziani aumentano
sapete che i tumori sono una tipica
patologia dell'età anziana quindi sono
un po l'altra faccia della aumento della
nostra età media e questi meritano
un'attenzione particolare perché spesso
non hanno soltanto il tumore ma hanno
anche altre malattie hanno altri
problemi possono avere un disagio
sociale avere una famiglia problematica
e quindi agli anziani dedichiamo un
attenzione particolare
come la dedichiamo a chi teme di avere
un tumore e non sempre per fortuna ce
l'ha anche quando c'è il sospetto che
queste persone devono avere rapidamente
una risoluzione diagnostica cioè non
possono stare in giro un mese un mese e
mezzo fare esami tutti noi sappiamo come
questo purtroppo tante volte si è ancora
presente la biologia molecolare per la
ricerca alcuni aspetti che riguardano le
ossa nel caso specifico e poi pensando
anche a quella fetta di pazienti giovani
che per fortuna sono una minoranza tra i
malati oncologici
ma capite bene che alcuni problemi come
la preservazione della fertilità sia nel
maschio che nella femmina e la
riabilitazione per tornare nel modo più
rapido e migliore possibile all'attività
quotidiana acquistano un rilievo
particolare per fare queste cose bisogna
lavorare insieme perché non è soltanto
l'oncologo non è soltanto il medico non
è soltanto chi sta in reparto di degenza
ma un equipe deve lavorare intorno al
malato
devo dire invece che su alcuni aspetti
siamo molto avanti per esempio questa
parola che è umanizzazione una parola
che non mi piace poi tanto perché
dall'idea che se non c'è l'umanizzazione
c'è una situazione bestiale non è così
per fortuna ma in realtà vuol dire
migliorare il modo di prendersi carico
del paziente per esempio abbellendo
l'ambiente creando l'ho sempre più
confortevole e facendo in modo che nel
periodo in cui un paziente sta in
ospedale si senta un po come a casa sua
gli aspetti psicologici perché tutti
sanno quanto questi malati possono avere
ansia depressione ed altro
e poi vi ho citato solo un aspetto che è
quello di un certo tipo di malattie
embolie trombosi tromboflebite che sono
particolarmente frequenti nei malati di
tumore e sui quali il nostro ospedale ha
da sempre una capacità di ricerca e di
clinica rivolta all'eccellenza anche dal
punto di vista ripeto della ricerca
clinica quindi ricerca assistenza vanno
di pari passo se noi facciamo una buona
ricerca miglioriamo anche l'assistenza e
non solo diamo accoglienza sollievo ai
pazienti ma li aiutiamo anche a fare
terapie sempre migliori sempre più
efficaci tutti questi aspetti vanno
tenuti insieme perché nessuno di questi
è superiore rispetto all'altro
paziente quindi al centro siamo in un
puzzle in una situazione complicata in
una situazione in cui qui i pezzi del
puzzle vanno insieme ma in realtà quando
una persona si ammala di cancro tutti i
pezzi vanno ciascuno dalla sua parte
e allora il compito di chi li assiste è
quello di mettere insieme con pazienza
tutti questi aspetti di rimettere ordine
di rimettere armonia laddove la malattia
crea una situazione di estrema
problematicità e di estrema difficoltà
dobbiamo sempre avere il paziente al
centro al di fuori di ogni retorica
paziente vuol dire che dobbiamo pensare
a lui a lei e gli altri aspetti che
fanno parte del puzzle devono essere
coniugati messi intorno al paziente
quindi un'assistenza di qualità
una ricerca e una formazione di
professionisti di vario tipo che si
occupino bene del paziente una riduzione
dei tempi di attesa e più in generale
del disagio che noi diamo a questi
pazienti e quando dico efficienza
economica non scandalizziamoci perché
oggi la assistenza e anche la ricerca
costano costano tanto e la comunità ha
il diritto di sapere che quello che
viene investito in questa attività sia
usato nel modo migliore quindi non è una
parolaccia
efficienza economica ma è un richiamo
alla responsabilita che dobbiamo avere
per seguire questi pazienti nel modo
migliore questa è un po la storia che io
ho visto in questi anni è una storia in
cui ci sono ancora a dio piacendo ed è
una storia in cui mi sento contento
perché mi sento di aver fatto gli sta
facendo qualcosa in cui credo
profondamente
ma non mi sento soddisfatto perché
soddisfatto
vorrebbe dire che i problemi sono stati
tutti risolti
abbiamo visto che ci sono varie luci in
questo semaforo e il mio auspicio è che
le luci rosse si spengano rapidamente e
che possiamo rapidamente andare verso un
quadro in cui la speranza e i risultati
siano sempre più vicino ai nostri
pazienti è un'esigenza giusta è
un'esigenza sentita e il messaggio che
concludo voglio dare è che io ma tutti
anche gli altri miei colleghi ovviamente
tutti quelli che lavorano con me tutti
quelli che lavorano intorno alla malato
ci sono e ci sono ogni giorno grazie
solo due parole rispetto a quello che ho
detto luce verde quindi che ci sia la
luce su questo che se una luce verde
quindi una luce che dà il via è una luce
e piena di speranza